Salut à tous c'est Pêcheurs de Trésors.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes à Agen.
Et on a trouvé un pont super sympa.
Regardez, c'est l'endroit idéal
pour pêcher à l'aimant
Bon, il y a un petit peu de ferraille
au bord.
Ça a sûrement déjà été fait
par d'autres pêcheurs à l'aimant
et peut être même par des abonnés.
Dites nous le si c'est
vous en commentaires.
Maintenant l'intro c'est terminé.
Ce qu'on va faire,
c'est qu'on va pêcher à l'aimant !
C'est parti
Allez j'ai quelque chose sous ce pont
super.
Oh le couteau est beau,
Oui en plus, mais alors là c'est
un super premier lancer ça.
Munition, Bien joué.
Alors ça, c'est un outil.
C'est quoi le deuxième nom qu'ils donnent aux bèches Quentin ?
En général les gens
une houe
et oui d'ailleurs.
On l'a pas dit tout à l'heure,
mais c'est le fameux pruneau d'Agen.
J'ai pas mal de choses
Preuve qu'il reste.
Ouah
Qu'est ce donc ?
On dirait un morceau de...
un cylindre de voiture
qui a été coupé en deux, on dirait.
Pourtant, c'est être très costaud ça
Bien sûr.
Rasta, toujours là, en pleine forme.
Vous voyez il a un harnais maintenant.
D'habitude, il était au collier et là,
il a l'air plus intelligent comme ça.
Tu montres, c'est bien.
Oh oh
Ah bah une pédale
sympa, pédale douce.
Pédale d'eau douce.
OK. Une canette
Voyons ce que l'on trouve sous ce pont
J'ai quelque chose.
Wow !
Bah ouais franchement
ok donc ça c'est un marteau
sans manche
Ça, c'est une pince à cliquet.
Peut être, on dirait
rien de très intéressant.
On a des choses.
Oh
Qu'est ce que c'est ?
Un oiseau
un jouet oiseau.
Et il bouge attends
C'est original
C'est drôle.
Si vous savez ce que c'est en commentaires
Un boulon,
un oui, un franc, un demi franc.
Alors est ce qu'on voit l'année ?
C'est 50 centimes de francs
Ah oui 50 centimes de francs
Pardon, c'est pas mon époque, ça.
J'arrive pas à lire l'année
Alors ça dit quoi de ton côté ?
Je vois.
C'est quoi un tournevis
Bien joué, pendant ce temps Rasta est bien là haut
sur son petit rocher.
Ah bah.
Sympa ça, on dirait un bracelet
c'est cuivré.
Regardez
On dirait un morceau d'un bracelet
cassé ou quelque chose comme ça.
Sympa.
Pas mal.
Des fois, il faut bien regarder l'aimant
parce que même quand on pense qu'on
a rien du tout en cherchant bien, là,
par exemple, on a une ogive,
Elle se met toute droite avec l'aimant
Donc bien sympa.
On va aller voir ce côté du pont.
Maintenant, il y a Baptiste
en espérant faire mieux.
Maintenant, c'est propre
je vais me mettre sur la dalle. Ici
Cet endroit a dû être fait par d'autres pêcheurs à l'aimant mais bon
On ne sait jamais.
En tout cas, c'est très sympa le coin. Là.
J'ai eu quelques trucs aussi.
Oui, effectivement, il y a des choses.
Ça, c'est une clé? C'est bien rempli quand même
Oui moi aussi, regarde
Une clef, ouais il reste
et ensuite le Cap Rousset, des sardines à l'huile de tournesol
ecoute...
Dommage qu'elle soit vide
il y a un os.
Attention Rasta
Momo bobo,
Il a failli tomber dans l'eau.
J'ai quelque chose
Ohhhh
Elle est magnifique
Ou c'est quoi ça ?
Mais arrête, attends
il y a quelque chose dedans
C'est une boîte,
mais c'est trop bien ça
Mais là, rien que les motifs sur la boîte,
c'est quoi ? Ils sont beaux,
ils sont pas abimés du tout
Mais ça fait des motifs style Renaissance.
non quand même pas
Ecoute. C'est trop bien.
Peut être. C'est une boite de bonbons
et on part en vrille
Il faut l'ouvrir par là.
Mais doucement,
je pourrais pas ? Il faut peut-être la nettoyer un peu avant.
Mais elle est encore hermétiques, il n'y a pas d'eau dedans.
Donc oui.
C'est un truc de dingue, trop stylé,
Là la trouvaille !
Peut-être que c'est juste un design ancien mais que c'est des bonbons
Magnifiques ça.
Magnifique !
Bravo ! C'est incroyable,
Tu sais qu'il
y avait un motif derrière aussi.
Regarde, mais comment ça peut être
encore hermétique.
C'est un truc de dingue.
Bah c'est encore bien fermé, c'est de la qualité
Il y a quelque chose à l'intérieur en plus
Ouverture en fin de vidéo !
Allez, je me suis décalé
un peu plus loin que le pont
On va voir ce que j'arrive
à trouver ici. Fais nous un beau lancer
Ah trop haut
Je ne sais pas si c'est à cause des algues
Mais j'ai quelques trucs je pense.
Alors une pièce
wow !
C'est un franc, ça il me semble.
On va essayer
de voir l'année.
C'est difficile à lire.
On verra plus tard. Oh,
un couteau
cassé !
Alors là, je viens de remonter mon aimant
Regarde il y a un peu de tout,
on a une lame de couteau.
AH ouais
On a trouvé la même hier
Et une pile
Ah bravo. Elle date celle là
Donc c'est une belle dépollution.
Et ça, j'ai cru que c'était un chargeur.
Mais non.
Ce n'est pas un
Ici j'ai un objet encombrant, regarde les bulles
c'est quoi ça ?
Regarde un piqué bizarre.
Il y a une sorte de flèche au bout
et un anneau à l'arrière,
je crois
C'est un piquet de péniche
Non, c'est pas un anneau, c'est intéressant ça.
C'est bien tordu, dîtes nous en commentaires si vous avez des idées
Ouais pour moi c'est juste un piqué
Qu'est-ce que tu nous sors de beau là ?
Des algues surtout
Et de la vielle ferraille
Il y a plein de choses dans ce canal.
Il est rempli encore une fois
Olala regarde
Moi aussi j'ai un couteau, mais rond
On est pas à l'abris d'une bonne surprise.
Non, ça c'est un morceau d'étrier
Et là, regardez ce qu'on a trouvé,
ce que Quentin a trouvé,
on va la filmer au téléphone pour Focus.
0,25€ d'anciens francs.
J'ai battus notre record d'ancienneté de pièces avec l'aimant non ?
C'est notre nouveau record c'était 1905, avant
Que c'est la plus ancienne
pièce qu'on ait pêché à l'aimant
en 1903.
Ça, c'est pour le coup, c'est bien joué.
Comme quoi c'est un vieux pont.
Belle découverte ? Oui,
Ah il y avait un vélo ici
Et un anneau gastrique
Ça a été fait, mais il en reste...
Oh damn...
Oh regarde comme elle est belle,
Elle n'est pas aimantée,
je crois autant si elle l'est
Elle est toute neuve. Non, c'est italien,
c'est du lire.
1976. Regarde, elle est comme neuve.
C'est du nickel. Regardez
j'hallucine
Les anciennes pièces italiennes résistent très bien à l'eau
On dirait qu'elle vient d'être fabriquée
Même pas une rayure.
Olala. Ah t'as une pièce de monnaie quand même
Ah oui, c'est 0,02€ d'euro.
Il y a sûrement eu un accident avec
une péniche qui transportait des clous.
Et des coffres forts.
Des clous et des coffres forts
qui venaient d'Italie d'ailleurs.
Tu connais l'expression
être dans les clous ?
C'est un peu ça.
Oh là là !
Et typiquement on est dans les clous.
OK, une clef à pipe là, elle est morte.
Et bien voilà.
Donc là, on a changé de spot.
On est un peu plus loin,
sous une passerelle piétonne,
mais il doit y avoir des choses
parce qu'on est à côté d'un stade, et
d'une école je pense
Donc c'est parti.
On va voir. Premier lancer
Avec notre aimant Barbarian de chez Maison
de la détection.
Baptiste.
Que ce que tu nous conseille
pour commencer la pêche à l'aimant ?
Le barbarian est un aimant qui a 1600 kilos de force.
1600 kilos, c'est énorme,
c'est le plus gros du marché.
Il faut savoir qu'il
y a différentes gammes d'aimants 360°
et en général
on conseille le terror pour démarrer.
Dans tous les cas, vous avez le choix,
vous avez le site qui est en description
et vous avez le code promo PECHEURDETRESORS qui offre 5% sur toute la boutique.
C'est parti
Op là ! J'aimerais bien trouver un vélo tout neuf
là bas, j'ai quelque chose.
J'ai quelque chose
Enfin
Oh oui un poids d'altère Baptiste
Tu vas être content toi qui aime faire du sport.
2,50€ le kilo.
Eh ben, il y a un kilo
Tu as gagné 2,5€
C'est bon ça
J'avais aussi une vieille clé
Pas des plus jolies, mais bon,
c'est sympa.
Une bague, peut être ?
Ah oui
J'ai trouvé une bague Baptiste,
une bague aimantée.
Ouais
Elle est très moche,
mais bon, ça reste une bague.
Quentin a quelque chose de gros
juste au bord.
Je l'envoie derrière
T'es dessus ?
Non
Je suis sur ton aimant
Non je ne pense pas
Ah non
C'est du béton armé, un scooter.
Ah ouais ?
T'es sûr ?? Oui oui
Bah allez !
C'est quoi le nom du club ?
Allez l'Aviron Agenais !
C'est super ce que vous faîtes
Eh bien merci beaucoup.
Il y a un scooter là
Je vais chercher le grappin ?
Pour qu'on le soulève un peu, après on l'attache
Je pense qu'on peut essayer comme ça
je reste comme ça moi
Donc là, on a repéré
ce qui semble être un scooter.
On va essayer de l'accrocher
avec le grappin
juste pour le rapprocher
un peu et l'attacher.
Parce que le mieuxc'est de l'attache
Comme un scooter ce n'est pas trop aimanté
autant directement l'attacher.
Donc j'ai l'aimant sur la roue arrière
Je vais essayer de le soulever
un peu plus haut pour grappiner
OK je vais l'attacher
Ouais mais du coup
on a pas de corde en plus
Il a l'air sympa !
Je pensais pas un truc trop lambda
et en même temps pas trop lourd
On va se casser le dos non ?
Peut être qu'on va réussir
Ah Rasta tu viens nous aider ?
Baptiste Rasta, il fait des bêtises.
Je sais pas si on arrive à deux par contre,
on va essayer.
Ouais c'est haut quand même
On va s'échauffer un peu le dos.
Ah mais j'ai vu que tu étais super puissant
T'as du monde sur le côté, demande leur de l'aide
Tu es chaud pour tirer ?
Il est motivé Baptiste
Allez
Tu viens avec moi ?
Je vais rester devant pour soulever
mets toi derrière
Il faut qu'il passe la marche,
on va tirer à deux sur la corde.
Ouais,
et après on va essayer de le monter.
Une fois qu'il a monté,
ça sera bon
C'est déjà pas mal là
Faudrait attraper l'arrière là
Ou le guidon
tenez comme ça
Le guidon ?
J'attrape le guidon.
Attends, je peux tirer ça. Déjà.
Oui on a besoin d'aide.
Il y a quelqu'un qui arrive
Attends un peu il arrive
Vous pouvez tirer sur la corde
Il ne veut pas passer par dessus
Ça fait longtemps qu'il est là ?
Vu la vase
Quelques mois je dirais
Là ça bloque
Allez go
Il faut remonter le guidon
On tire à trois : 1,2,3
C'est limite
ouais
Il faudrait une autre personne
Le monsieur du club arrive
Attention qu'il ne retombe pas
Il va retomber
C'est le plastique qui se casse
j'ai reçu de la vase dans la bouche
On va avoir de l'aide.
Bah c'est vrai que à deux, c'est impossible.
Ou alors il faut le treuil et tout mais c'est une galère
Allez on est prêts ?
Go ! 1,2,3
Ah vite ! On y est presque
Ouais
ouais ouais.
Enfin bien joué !
Oh oh !
Bravo et merci !
Il est quand même lourd! Belle bête
bravo pour votre chaîne quand même. Merci beaucoup
C'est "pêcheur de trésors".
Sympa.
Merci beaucoup pour le coup de main.
En tout cas.
Bon, il n'y a pas de plaque, on dirait.
il n'y a rien dedans, non ?
OK. Ben ouais, entre quelques semaines
et quelques mois,
il a eu le temps de rouiller quand même.
Oh oui, nickel !
Que peut on faire de ce scooter ?
N'y a pas la plaque, donc on va juste
appeler la mairie pour qu'ils le récupère.
On va le mettre à côté des poubelles.
En tout cas, un grand merci
aux abonnés qui nous ont aidés
et aux non abonnés qui nous ont aidés.
Parce que c'est vrai
que les gens nous aident
même quand ils nous connaissent pas.
Ça, ça fait très plaisir.
Et pour ceux qui savent,
le modèle aussi dites le nous en commentaires
Il roule bien encore
Ouais
On va faire quelques photos et un tour avec
Pour ceux qui se rappellent,
il y a tout juste trois ans et demi,
on était à peu près
sur le même type de scène et avec Quentin,
on avait remonté notre premier scooter
qu'on était en train de tester.
Mais c'était une de nos vidéos
qui avait le plus marché à l'époque.
Et j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour vous remercier.
On n'aurait jamais pensé
être près de 390000.
Trois années après,
la vidéo est en description.
Par contre, pas un seul,
une seule trace d'essence quand on l'a remonté
Je pense que nous n'avons pas percé le réservoir.
On peut regarder d'ailleurs
de toute façon s'il en reste
Est ce qu'on va le siphonner lui aussi ?
La dernière fois on l'avait siphonné
Cette fois ci,
Il n'est pas percé donc je pense que
Soit ils sont en panne d'essence
et c'est pour ça qu'ils l'ont jeté.
Oh il est plein
Ah ouais, ça serait con de jeter ça
On a rien pour siphonner ?
C'est
de la vraie essence. Il n'est pas percé,
on l'a la poire à siphon
On peut tenter
C'est galère d'y accéder dans la voiture ?
Non elle est devant
on tente, mais on a pas de bidon,
on a la bouteille à l'arrière de Coca.
Ouais, vas y
Allez on test
J'ai aperçu déjà quelque chose.
Et oui, l'antivol de vélo.
Les antivols comme ça. Franchement, on peut presque les couper avec les dents
Il était coupé.
C'est dommage.
Mais c'est nul. Mettez pas ça.
Ça ne sert à rien.
On mais j'ai une chaîne aussi.
Un collier plaqué, ça, du plaqué
Il reste du cuivre. OK.
Elle est un peu cassée
mais je peux la mettre quand même.
Je pense
C'est horrible.
D'accord
filtre à gazole
et ça avec un crochet.
Je sais pas trop
Attention.
Oh mon amortisseur de vélo !
Et ça...
c'est une imprimante.
Je pense, ou une machine à écrire
peut être,
mais je dirais imprimante
ok et ouais un amortisseur
de scooter ou de mobylette
aller.
Oui, il y a des trucs.
Le couteau.
Attention Quentin,
mais il est beau celui là.
Tu peux t'en servir
un couteau,
On en a trouvé pas mal aujourd'hui
J'ai quelque chose.
Oh
Un ordinateur ?
Non non, je crois que c'est une plaque
une plaque de cuisson je crois
C'est bon je l'ai
Lecteur dvd, cassettes Sony
ok. Mais ça en moins dans l'eau.
Bonne dépollution.
Ouais, ça fait plus de cassettes
que de DVD non compatibles.
Disques. Les disques.
Et il y a des choses.
Là, il y a plein de choses.
Qu'est ce que tu sors de beau ?
Je fais une remontée en direct ?
Je la dédicace aux jeunes de l'aviron, là.
On va voir ce qu'on a
T'as pas tant que ça. Une serrure.
C'est une serrure, ça. Voilà.
Non c'est un block carré. Ah il y a une pièce quand même
0,01€.
Ça paie le lancer.
Ah bon ça paie le lancer ?
Ils ne sont pas cher mes lancers alors !
Oui toute la journée on jette les aimants
une montre
Une montre de collection,
Elle est horrible
c'est du toc
Et en plus elle a pris chez moi,
ça reste une montre.
Je suis content.
Alors regardez, je viens de retrouver
une relique du passé.
Un Handspinner
Est ce qu'il fonctionne ? Non,
il est rouillé, il ne fonctionne plus.
Tiens Rasta
Je te l'offre.
Il ne veux pas.
Qu'est ce qu'on a ?
J''ai déjà vu ça.
J'ai déjà vu ça,
mais je ne sais plus trop ce que c'est.
Oh j'ai plein de choses.
Encore un cadenas
Cadenas pas cassé.
Deux piles, donc ça c'est intéressant.
Bonne dépollution,
plus ce sachet plastique
et ça c'est un porte clés intéressant.
Peugeot
c'est un peu collector peut être ?
Ça vient d'un garage Peugeot.
Sympa.
Les plus forts reconnaîtront avec le logo,
mais ça c'est l'ancien, c'est l'ancien.
Et il a un moment celui là
il me semble. Le logo Peugeot.
Donc ce lion, un petit souvenir d'Agen
Faute de ramener des pruneaux,
on va ramener des porte clés.
Ok encore une pile.
Allez, j'ai pas mal de trucs
Celui qui a la meilleure découverte.
Paie l'apéro
Ha ben voilà un autre couteau,
En aussi bon état que l'ancien.
Franchement. Je prends ! Il y a le service de couverts entier
Je prends
Elle est sympa la couleur.
Je croyais que c'était la vase,
mais c'est la vraie couleur
et un peu abimé au bout.
Dommage.
OK, une paire de ciseaux
et encore une pile.
C'est incroyable le nombre de piles qu'il y a ici
Quentin on travaille un objet, là
ça vient
Allez vas y
C'est pas si lourd.
mais c'est dans la vase
en plein milieu presque
Oh ça c'est de la suspension.
Suspension de moto ?
Ouais, pas très vieille
je regarde si elle marche
Vas y
Il y a l'aimant qui gène
C'est bon comme neuve.
Salade d'algues ! Ouais, mais pas que.
C'est
C'est un porte bagages de scooter ou de vélo, non ?
Moto ? Ouais, ouais.
Porte bagages.
Qu'est ce que j'ai encore ?
oalla
c'est le reste de l'imprimante.
La suite
Et un sachet vide
Allez
Oui, un tabouret
et une fourchette.
Après les couteaux, la fourchette
Ce soir tu manges avec
Alors t'as des trucs ?
ça commence a être propre
On a fait toute cette portion.
On sait qu'elle est Clean.
Si vous voulez une partie 2 à Agen
dites le nous en commentaire.
Partie trois même Quentin. Oui partie 3
Opopo
De la salade, il y a un truc, un truc.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Couteau suisse, ah non
Et un pochon ?
Un pochon aimanté ?
bah ouais
C'est une vis
On l'ouvre ?
Vous êtes prêts pour la dinguerie ?
Des bijoux
peut être.
Des écrous, et une vis...
C'etait sûr.
Il y a eu un accident.
Le cache de ma montre s'est ouvert.
Donc là, vous pouvez apercevoir que c'est
de la très bonne horlogerie.
Du style Rolex, que du mécanisme
à mouvement perpétuel, voilà en vrai.
À l'intérieur
est pas si si abîmé que ça
Oui il a bien résisté à l'eau
Baptiste, tu paries sur quoi ?
Alors franchement,
on a plein de pronostics,
on a dit des dents
mais ça sonne pas comme des dents
Non, on a dit des bijoux, mais ça parait
comme étant plein de petites choses.
Moi, je reste sur des dents
Wim pense peut être des munitions
de plomb ou de munitions fusils
Des petites billes. Oui peut être.
Ou des diamants.
Moi je dis que c'est une chaîne en or
Moi je dis que c'est des dents
Moi aussi je reste sur des dents
des dents de lait de gamin
ça se nettoie petit à petit
Oh !
C'est des.
C'est quoi ?
Des perles, des perles ?
Par contre boîte, elle est terrible,
elle est en argent
Ouais elle est plaquée argent
des perles ?
C'est pour faire un petit bracelet,
un collier.
Mais en quoi ?
Oh !
la couleur du sang
OK. On fait appel à vous
pour l'expertise de ces pierres.
Alors selon nous,
ça vient certainement d'un chapelet
puisqu'en effet
on peut voir la présence de graines.
Voilà, c'est la fin de cette vidéo
de pêche à l'aimant
Vous le voyez, le coffre est bien rempli.
Bon, on a triché un peu, il
n'y a pas qu'une session là, mais c'est déjà pas mal.
On a du bon poids.
On se dit à la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant !